.
Mélissa François.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans l'enceinte rouge et or,
la cérémon d de clôture
du Parti communiste chinois
est un événement chorégraphié
au quart de tour.
Un incident semble avoir fait
craquer le vernis reluisant
du congrès quand des employés
ont demandé à l'ancien président
Hu Jintao de quitter sa place.
OnOn l'empêche de saisir
ses documents. L'employé insiste
en l'agrippant sous le bras.
Il semble finalement obtempérer
contre son gré, devant l'air
impassible du président Xi.
Après un long silence,
les autorités ont expliqué
qu'il avait eu un ennui de
santé, mais selon cet analyste,
d'autres hypothèses ont été
soulevées pour justifier
ceetetrait.
BENOÎT HARDY-CHARTRAND,  prof.
Université Temple à Tokyo
- Xi Jinping qui veut lancer,
envoyer un message à certains
haut placés du Parti communiste
qui peut-être ne voudraient pas
suivre la ligne du parti ou
qui seraient contre la prise
de pouvoir de Xi Jinping.
ANDRÉ LALIBERTÉ, prof. études
politiques, Univ. d'Ottawa
- Cette expulsion, franchement,
manu militari de Hu Jintao,
encore une fois, c'est un peu...
ça ne paraîpapas très bien.
Ça donne une image, franchement,
sinistre des luttes de pouvoir à
l'intérieur du Parti communiste.
- Car  t terme du congrès,
un nouveau comité central
de 205 personnes a été désigné.
Il nommera par la suite les
25 membres du bureau politique
et au sein de celui-ci, les sept
membres du comité permanent.
Il s'agit du coeur du pouvoir
chins,s, qui sera composé de
personnes loyales à Xi Jinping,
qui devrait être reconduit
à la présidence chinoise
pour une troisième fois.
- Ce n'est pas une surprise
pour personne, mais ça fait
de Xi Jinping, clairement,
le leader le plus important,
le plus influent, le plus
puissant depuis Mao Zedong,
qui est mort en 1976.
- Pour se maintenir au pouirir,
l'homme fort de la Chine
avait fait supprimer de
la constitution la limite
de deux mandats.e e congrès du
Parti communiste s'est déroulé
sur fond de ralentissement
économique et de tensions avec
l'Occident.  g gouvernement
devrait aussi maintenir
sa stratégie zéro COVID,
malgré ses conséquences sur
les inststries et la population.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Et on poursuit avec
Guy Saint-Jacques, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Chine
Bonsoir, M. Saint-Jacques.
- Bonsoir, Mme Bourbonnais.
- Donc, quoi penser tout d'abord
de cette scène étonnante
dans le cadre d'un événement
hyper chorégraphié?
GUY SAINT-JACQUES, ancien
ambaadadeur du Canada en Chine
- Bien moi, j'ai trouvé ça
extraordinaire parce que
je n'ai jamais rien vu de ça.
Puis en fait, si on regarde
aussi d'autres systèmes
communistes, comme à l'époque
de l'Union soviétique,
je n'ai jamais rien vu comme ça.
Dans ce cas-ci, en fait,
puisque c'est la réunion du
Parti communiste, le secrétaire
général du parti, Xi Jinping, a
obtenu tout ce qu'il voulait
lors du congrès. Hu Jintao,
manifestement, n'était pas
d'accord avec ça,
et peut-être que M. Xi a craint
que Hu Jintao veuille faire
un coup d'éclat. Les gens qui
sont venus enlever M. Hu o
attendu que tous les
journalistes soient en position
pour que ça soit filmé. Une
humiliation commçaça, c'est une
perte de face envers un leader
qui était dans la même position
que Xi Jinpingl l y a à peine
10 ans, et de procéder comme ça,
moi, je pense que ça va créer
beaucoup dmemertume,
de ressentiment parmi
les gens du parti.
Parce que pourquoi faire ça
publiquement? Pourquoi humilier
une personne? On voit comment
aussi les autres dirigeants
qui étaient assis, comment
ils étaient mal à l'aise.
L'autre message, c'est à
la société chinoise, c'est de
dire : "Regard, , je suis
maintenant en charge de tout et
il faut que vous fassiez ce que
je vous demande de faire." Ça
s'appliqueusussi bien au secteur
privé qu'à tout le monde.
- Oui, donc il y a plein de
choses que vous venez de dire.
Danse e fond, c'est que, bon,
les médias officiels chinois,
eux, ont indiqué qu'il ne se
sentait pas bien. Alors, on peut
peut-être remettre en question
on verra bien. Mais pourquoi
se serait-on... pourquoi
on se serait empressé, en fait,
de censurer le nom de Hu Jintao
par exemple sur les réseau
sociaux après cet événement?
C'est ce qu'on rapporte.
Et le symbole est très fort
aussi, faire disparaître son
prédécesseur, qui étt t reconnu
comme étant un réformateur.
Donc c'est comme si on effaçait
une partie du passé.
- Oui, tout à fait, puis
en fait, on sait qu'il y a
des factions au sein du
Parti communiste, ce n'est pas
un parti monolithique.
L'autre grand absent de
ce congrès, c'est l'ancien
président Jiang Zemin, qui a
96 ans, dont l'état de santé est
trop mauvais pour qu'il puisse
assister. Mais là, c'était
un message clair à toutes
les autres factions :
"Il est trop tard pour vous
opposer, c'est moi le nouveau
grand patron et je suis
tellement fort que je peux
poser ce geste humiliant."
Je trouve ça immature de la part
de Xi Jinping.
- Et des événements
qui pourraient refroidir
les investisseurs étrangers, qui
le sont déjà par la politique
zéro COVID de Xi Jinping?
- Oui, tout à fait, puis en fait
aussi, déj, , dans le secteur
privé chinois, il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes parce qu'au cours
des dernières années,
le président est intervenu
mettre des contrôles
sur les grandes compagnies
comme Alibaba ou Didi.
Il a parlé de cette notion
de prospérité commune, deredistt
les échos que j'ai de beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs chinois,
c'est qu'ils sdidisent :
"Bien, ça commence à être plus
difficile de faire des affaires.
Est-ce que c'est le temps de
quitter?" Et puis le secteur
privé, c'est celui qui crée
le plus d'emplois en Chine.
Ça fait que donc il risque
d'y avoir des répercussions,
bien sûr, auprès des compagnies
étrangères, mais aussi de fortes
répercussions en Chine même.
- Au plan économique.
Merci beaucoup, M. Saint-
Jacques, d'avoir été avec no